[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長です今日は私が買っ
ているヘラクレスオカブのスキン教報告
ですよろしくお願いしますはいあの私初め
社長ですね2023年の5月末に
ヘラクレスオカブトのオストメスを買い
ましてどこで育てようかなって思ったら
あの偶然700万円で買った核シェルター
が空いてましてその700万円の角
シェルターを虫かごとしてあのヘラクレス
ベアとして使っていますで今10月末大体
5ヶ月ぐらいが経ちましたがあの今まで3
本ぐらい動画出しててめせであの交尾して
ましたとか卵を産んでえ今780匹幼虫が
いますとかで幼虫がめちゃくちゃ空ってま
すって話まできったんですけれどもまあ
こう9月10月結構いろんなことがあり
ましたのでそれまとめて動画にしてやり
ます是非ご覧ください
どうぞもうね幼虫の数かなり増えましたあ
今そこ幼虫いますね個体によってね全然
成長の速度が違っててこの箱に入ってる
やつはずっと撮影し続けてるんですけれど
もこいつが多分今一番大きいのかななんか
太いのよねめっちゃ太くなってますこの子
まちょっとどの容器よりも大きいのを使っ
て
今育ててるんですけれどもま今後全部ね
より大きくなっていく気がします成虫は相
変わらず元気
です今ちょっとおねなのかな湿度管理も
完璧ですはいこんな感じです8月中旬
はいえ突然すいません今日が8月の20日
8月の20日なんですけれどもえ
ヘラクレスの餌を変えようと思って今全部
新しいゼリに変えたんですけれども
え8月20日
で多分これはもう死んでるのかな
ヘラクレスガブの店がえ死んでしまいまし
たそうね結構寝たり潜ったりでずっとして
いたのでどのタイミングで死んでしまった
のかが分からないんですけれども多分ね
最近だと思いますここら辺で死んでて
ちょっとびっくりしましたねやっぱり卵を
産んだりするとすごい弱ってしまうって
いうのを聞いたんですけれども本当に
気づいたらなくなってましたいやちょ
悲しいです
ねめちゃくちゃ餌減ってて絶対遅1匹じゃ
食べれない量の餌が減ってたので最近まで
元気かなと思ってたんですけれども力尽き
てしまいました君の子供は責任を持って
育てたいと思いますオはね全然まだ元気な
のよねびっくりするぐらいわごめんなさい
いつも敵むき出しなんですけどもスはまだ
全然元気ですはい8月20日お盆が終わっ
たくらいの出来事でし
たどうも8月松です7月2日に孵化した
幼虫の土のヘリが早すぎるこれもうパまで
土入ってたんですけど今見たらもうなんか
2割ぐらいがなくなって食べられてます
ちょっと土を追加してあげましょうの
ついでに大きさも見てみようかじゃあ入れ
ていきます
ね1回ちょっと幼虫の大きさ見てみ
ましょうかすごいサイズになってると思う
んだよの失礼しますこれ全部ふなのかな
なんかすごい硬いのがたくさんあるけどえ
待っ
てめっちゃでかいんだ
けどめっちゃでかいんだけど俺手めっちゃ
でかい方なんだけどそれでもこのサイズ
ちょっと戻しますねはいいやでっけえ
たる見てこれモンスターやんえでも綺麗な
んじゃない1ヶ月でこれよはいちょっと土
を戻していきますなんか土を変える時が
一番なんか気をつけなきゃいけないらしく
ていつもと違う環境になっちゃうから土
買えすぎるとなんかストレスでやばい
らしいんですよね今の土をちょっと残し
ながら新しい土を増やしてあげたいと思い
ますそうだよないきなり環境変わってもや
だよなはいこれ幼虫です戻し
ます元気に生けるんだぞあとは新しい土を
入れてあげます7月の頭に生まれたので2
ヶ月ぐらいで土交換したらいいって聞い
てるので多分ねもうこの8月末とか9月頭
に土変えちゃうのは全然ありな気がします
こんな食べるんだって感じだよ本当に
なくなるんだもん土がはいみんな覚えとい
てねこの土の量もうパンパンだからはい
こういう感じでちょっとあのの幼稚の土
かしていき
ますどうも2023年の9月の7日8月が
終わったんですけどまだちょっと暑い季節
ですね今日はとても大きな作業をしようと
思ってます今日する作業は幼虫の土全部
チェンジでございますこれがすごい大変
カブトムシの幼虫何を食べてるかというと
マット土をもうずっと食べ続けるんですよ
だからどんどん幼虫大きくなっていくに
つれて食べる土の量も増えるで土ね減るん
ですよ食べとこれとかもね見てもう元々ね
マンパに入ってた土がねもう3割ぐらい
食べちゃっててかなりスカスカになっ
ちゃってますたからめちゃくちゃ大きく
なってるのよきっとうわ分かるかわかん
ないけどめっちゃでっかい幼虫ここいるの
よちょ後でお見せするんですけどこれとか
もすごい減り方してるなこれもねパンパン
に入ってたんですけどももう3割ぐらい
なくなってるかないやたくさん食べてて
いいことなんですけれども土が減ってくと
同時に幼虫もしてもうなんかワンチャン
ね土じゃなくてほぼの中に住んでような
幼虫もひょっとしたらいるかもしれないの
で土を全部新しく変えていかなければいけ
ないという作業がありますそれがね大体
23ヶ月に1回やればいいよって言われて
てま一番早く生まれたやつが7月の最初
ぐらいだったのでまちょうど2ヶ月ぐらい
で土の減り方もかなり早いのでそろそろ
変えるタイミングかなと思って今日は幼虫
の土を全部変えていきたいと思いますただ
幼虫の数がすごい多いんですよもう卵から
帰ったのも最近いるから全部忘れたら50
超えてますね50匹以上のお部屋のお掃除
をしなければいけないという作業を今日
やっていきたいと思いますなおヘラクレス
の成虫とても元気です今日もかっこいいね
この中もそろそろ卵また増えてるんかな
確認しないとたくさん作業ありますが
頑張っていきたいと思います23ヶ月1回
の大作業ですはい土なんですけれども一応
幼虫によって使うマットを分けてます3
種類のマットでこ幼虫によってね違う
マットを使って育でてみてます近所の
ホームセンターに売ってたヘラクレス用の
マットですねなんかね意外とこういうので
も全然争奪気がしてます次がこれえキノコ
マットって言われるなんか結構ネットで
評判のいいヘラクレスが大きく育つよって
いうマットですいい状態を保つためにガス
とか入って密封されててガス抜きしなきゃ
いけなくて今こういう感じでガス抜きが
終わった状態で置いてあります次がこちら
バ師匠ひかさんが作られたマットヒカ
マットタイプBというやつです色がね全然
ね違うのよ土なんか黒いんですけどもこれ
も使って幼虫育てていますのでちょっと
怖いのがねその土変えると環境の変化で
ストレスで死んじゃう幼虫とか出るらしい
のでこのマットを使って空ててたやつは
このマットキノコマットで育ててつは
キノコマットこのマットを使ってたやつは
このマットっていう感じでマットは買えず
に土だけ変えていきたいと思いますが結局
土は変わらなくても多少の変化は起き
ちゃうんでちょっと今入ってる土を残し
ながら新しい土を入れるっていうのが
なんかベストな気がしますじゃあやって
いきましょうはいというわけで早速見て
いきましょうまずはずっと撮影していた
このケースの中の幼虫見ていきます多分
1番育ってるやつ孵化したのが7月の4日
なのでちょうど2ヶ月ちょっと経った
ぐらいですね土を変えるタイミングだと
思います見てないのよどれくらい大きく
なったかどこにいるかも分からん誰かも
わからんちょっと出していきますごめん
なさい
ね寝てるところひっくり返していい気持ち
のやはいないよ俺だったらぶち切れてる
出していき
ますいたええ
でかちょっと待ってカブトムシだったら
もうさぎになるタイミングレベルの大きさ
よあでかいでかいでかいうわプリプリの
エビみたいでっけえ確実に育っていますね
これは俺の湯ぐらいの太さだよ今これとか
これふなのかなちょっとわかんないけど
絶対土変えるべきタイミングなので変えて
いきたいと思いますでこの中に新しい土
入れてくわけなんですけどちょっとだけ今
入ってる土も入れながらやりますじゃ
ちょっと土入れたところで幼虫戻していき
ます新しいじゃたくさん食べるんだ
ぞあ入れ方むいはい
[音楽]
でかいなマジで入れていき
ますあすごい寝り打ってる鳴らし
ますうんいい量じゃないかなこれでまず1
匹完了ですえこの作業をあと
え50回以上やっていきます行きますね7
月4日不いや減ってるな土行きますもう
バンていくわ
もううわぼちぼちのサイズですねこれでも
大きいのにさっきのがでかすぎて小ちゃく
感じるはい
はいお帰りでかいんだよなこれでもはい
オッケーですこのサイズまで行くともうね
そんなに水分とかは必要ではあるんです
けど幼虫とか卵の時みたいに水分ビチビチ
じゃなくていいらしいです7月18日付
これもめっちゃ土減ってるなくり返します
はいあでもそんなに大きくないなカップに
入っていたんですけど今後この子大きく
なる可能性があるので大きいきに変えます
はい具育つんだぞお前のため
に4人部屋準備したからよしオッケー8月
10日果たしてどうなってるんでしょう
かでもなんかソシャゲのガチャしてる
みたいちっちゃあんまり食べれてなかった
のかなでも順当に育ってる気もするな8月
10日でしょ1ヶ月も経ってないぐらい
です
ね戻しますバイバイごめんなさいプリン
カップに入れたんですけど大きくなる予想
で大きいの言としますよしオッケー7月
18えでかくなってる1ヶ月半ぐらいする
と結構大きくなるっぽいですねすごいな
ちゃんと育ってる個体がたくさんいて安心
ですこれは7月187月
24おらああまあいい成長具合ですねバイ
バイよしオッケー多分1番土が減ってまし
た7月孵化したやつどうなってんだろうな
行きます
うわそこそこでかいなんか俺幼虫どっちか
というとキモいって思ってたタイプの人間
なんですけどこんだけプリプリだとなんか
美味しそうに感じるんだよなもっと
美味しい土ありますはいお引っ越し完了
です8月11多分ねそんな育ってない気が
しますよ割と最近孵化したってことでしょ
土が硬いぞえぎゅぎゅ詰めちょいました
けど土そんな食べてなさそうだったので
結構残しながら行きましょうかもう見る
からにが少ないからな土が合ってなかっ
たのかもしれないただ成長していたので
まあまあ
いいでしょうはい越し完了です7月12日
約2ヶ月でどれぐらい変化してるの
でしょうか
はいでかめっちゃ大きくなっとるやんけ
自分ちょっと元もたった土をもらいつつ
はいよいしょ気に育てよはいお引越し完了
です7月付この頃こんな生まれるって
わかんなくて日日まで書いてないんだよ
だいぶ土が減ってますけどもどうでしょう
かはいうわあでかい結構でかいなちゃんと
順当に育ってますねいいぞ美味しい土ぞ
なんかこいつめっちゃ食いそうだなはい
移動完了ですはいこういう感じでえ
どんどんやっていきたいと思いますこれで
販のヘラクリスマット終わったので他の血
で育って出る幼虫も変えていきたいと思い
ます8月10日うん結構最近だからま
そんなに大きくなってないでしょうこの
キノコマットっていうのがねネットで有名
なんすよすごく大きく育ちますって実際の
ところわかんないからなやってみるとああ
1ヶ月せずともこの大きさか結構育ってる
んじゃないかちょっと期待の意味も込めて
プリンクカップから卒業させるか育てよ
期待の星をバイ
バイなんかサラサラしてるのが特徴な気が
するキノコマットはいお引越し完了です8
月4日まちっちゃいでしょわかんない
キノコだから馬成長してる可能性がある
そしてこれひょっとしたら死んでるやつと
かもいるかもしんないから怖いんだよな
でか1ヶ月でこの成長
か君才能あるね元ある土を交いつつお
引っ越し
タイしっかり育ってねお引っ越し完了7月
28日行きますはいでかうわすごいな
キノコマッてやっぱ大きいのか育つ時
頑張ってな越完了7月28うわめっちゃ
減ってるお前だけ食べたんだえ2匹出てき
たんだけどあえどういうこと待って待って
なん
でちょっと待って
えなんで分身したいやいいけどでもなんか
やっぱ成長さがすごいな全然育ち方違うよ
2匹並べてみてもいやけどまあ2匹入れて
も育つっていうのが実証されたな
じゃあお前らここでお別れえどっから湧い
てきた確実に俺たち分けたぞやばすぎ
小さい卵があったどうするかわいそうだ
から
ではいえっとすいません
えあのリスナーさんの皆様の水用棒で2人
を話して欲しくないという声がたくさん
ありますのでちょっと実験的にこの2匹は
一緒に育ててみたいと思います共食いとか
しないってことだよね大丈夫だよねここ
まで育ったんだから大丈夫だと思いたい
けど距離は取らせておきますねじゃあき
行きますお幸せに7月の28土の減りは
そんなにないですけども
どうでしょうあいるねいますねはいはい
はいはいすごい土硬かったんかなこれ硬
すぎても食べづらそうだな食めば
いいよし完了7月28あ結構食べてる感じ
はあるはいあでかい1日2日違いで生まれ
た子でも全然大きさの感じが違うな何が
影響すてるんだろうま個体さというか
生まれ持った体格とかもあるんかなでも俺
一緒やぞお元気
でボンボキノコマットのラスト月27日
はいうわ減ってなそうどうなん
だろうはいああいたいたいたあまあまあ
まあまあまあ順当に育ってるのかな入れ
ますはいよっしゃはいチ完了次は私の
ヘラクレスの師匠ひかさんが作った土最近
生まれた幼虫に使ってるのでまだそんな土
を変える必要がないんですけど2匹だけ見
てみたいと思います8月14はいあいる
うわすごいまだちょっと大きさの実感は
分からないけどしっかり育ってはいますね
まだプリンクカップでいい気がするかな
引っ越しだようんまだ分からないねこんな
もんか
なオッケーだと思いますじゃ次多分これが
一番違うたってるな8月10
日なんかね白い点々ができてくるのでこれ
は変えておいて正解な気がしますねコバエ
とかの卵なのかいやこれキノコだなあれ
キノコだなこれ皆さん分かるかどうかなん
ですけどまキノコなんですよこれキノコ
生えたりするのって決して悪いことじゃ
なくて栄養がありすぎてこうなっちゃって
るってことなのでこれいい土の証拠なん
ですカ同士の土からキノコ入るんだねそれ
びっくりだよおいました順調に育ってる
感じはありますかと言ってキノコだらけに
なってもちょっと嫌なので土は変えておき
ますか大きいヘラクレス育てる時はそれ
くらいあっていいのかもしれないね栄養素
はいオッケーですじゃあ元気に育って
くださいねはいというわけで土の入れ替え
全部終わりました全部の土が新しくななっ
たので次土交換するのはま23ヶ月後
でしょ多分11月の後半とか12月半ばと
かになる気がしますもう本当にね
ぶっちゃけ幼虫をやることないんですよ
ただただ土食べてもらってで水分多すぎて
なんかカとか生えると危険なのでそれだけ
ちょっとチェックしながらっていう感じで
もうありすぎねま基本的にでもやることは
ないと思うのでこんな感じで続けていき
たいと思い
ますお久しぶりです9月の28日9月の末
もう10月ですねほぼ結構気温も涼しく
なってきましたがヘラクレスたちの様子は
どうなっているのでしょうか見ていき
ましょう温度がまあ22.3Cほど良い
温度をキープしておりますまずは成虫元気
か
ほいあれあいたいたいた押すなんか大丈夫
かあまり見ない角度のとこにいるな元気か
あめちゃくちゃ元気だわめちゃくちゃ元気
だわあずっと元気
ねかっこいいあやばいなんかよりそう元気
になってる気がするな容器もねちょっと
この卵を産みやすいケースから変えようか
なと思ってますいやずっとかっこいい
なあなたの子供は元気に育っているの
でしょうか幼虫見ていきましょうはい幼虫
どうなっているでしょうかまだ卵の間のも
ありますねこれとか孵化してるねもう幼虫
になってるはいもうそろそろのやつも結構
ありますね幼虫で1番大きかったやつ7月
4日に孵化したやつま8910と約3ヶ月
ぐらい経った幼虫の大きさちょっと見てみ
たいと思いますどれぐらいのサイズになっ
てんだろうなもう全くケトもつかんけど
もうこの容器だと小さい気もするんだよ
ないたいたいたいたいましたいましたい
ました
はい待ってちょっと待ってくれ
えっと化け物いやでっかはいもうこの大き
さだと多分オかスカの見分けができる
みたいです多分腹部にちょっとそれがあ
るっぽいんですけど見てみましょうか
ごめんねいっていっていった
え噛んだ噛んだ明人えめっちゃ噛まれたん
だけどちょっと待って怖い怖いけど腹部
だけ腹部だけ失礼しますごめんなさい
ね判断が難しいです僕いやちょっとマジで
わかんないな細かい判断の仕方はもう
ちょっとこの大きさの用地が増えてから
まめてチェックしたいと思います
とりあえず今こんなサイズになってると
いう動画でし
たはいこんにちは10月10日です
ヘラクレスのオスは相変わらず元気
いっぱいです
ねちょっとコバエが結構気になるなまその
分湿気があるということでま許すで1番
育ってるのが多分これなんですけどやばい
んすよ土の減り方が見てくださいもう半分
ぐらいなくなっちゃうんですよいやどん
だけ食べとるんていう感じなんですけども
ちょっとこの容器だとそろそろ小さい個体
が出てきたので大きい容器に変えたいと
思いますこっちの容器からこっちの容器に
移したいと思います7月2日に孵したから
もう89103ヶ月経ってますね3ヶ月目
の大きさこれ全部多分なのよ
そして知らんけどはさすがにいらない
からちょっとどかし
ますやっば待って待ってやばいやばい
やばいやばい見て大きさ見てもう怪物だ
うわ
でっか
このサイズまでいくとやっぱ容器は大きい
方がいいですねちょっとストレスになら
ないようにちょっとだけ前の土を入れて
おきますいきなり感変ってもあれなので
あとはえっと同じメーカーの土をもうタフ
入れてあげましょうこの土もすごいもう
しばらくしたらだいぶ食べられるんだろう
なこんだけ入れとけばまあ大丈夫でしょう
はいお引っ越し完了です容器でっかもう
この希望感になってきますよ1匹のお部屋
がこれで多分お腹いっぱい食べれるのでは
ないかなと思いますはいあのずと撮影して
たこの撮影しやすいワイドのゲージあるん
ですけどやっぱり土の減り方が早いですね
そして中の子がもバカでかいんすよ見て
これ分かるかなりでかくて幅が狭すぎて
結構窮屈そうなのでえもうワイドで育て
られないような気がしました苦しそうこれ
もちょっと大きい大きに映したいと思い
ます1回ちょっと幼虫出していきたいと
思いますもうかなり涼しくなって多分
ヘラクレスからすると過ごしやすい温度
シェルターの外でも今223ccぐらいだ
と思いますじゃ開けます
さすがに狭いよなこれだ
[音楽]
と寝てたらごめん
なもう行ったかなあいたいたたたたいまし
たいましたうわでっけえ
[音楽]
でっか俺の指より太いです
もう痛い痛い痛いなんか噛む噛む噛むはい
ちょっと大部屋に移してあげたいと思い
ますはい
はい元々あった土をまたちょっと入れて
幼虫
移動はいでっかもうこれやばい大きさだな
狭かったドにごめんなはいこんなもんかな
ちょっとね本当は横でずっと見ていき
たかったんですけどもうサイズ的に無理な
気がし
ますだって見てこれはちょっとこのよぎだ
とかわいそうでしたね大きくなってきた
ことはちょっとお部屋交換しながっていき
たいと思い
ますはいどうもえ2023年の10月の
11日ですヘラクレスを買たの5月の25
日だからま大体6月頭ぐらいで今10月の
頭だから7891-401
C完璧な温度調整はできています幼虫も
スクスクと育っていますががただもう外が
かなり涼しくなってきたのでちょっと
ヘラクレスたちの体調が心配だなっていう
時にヘラクレスのスの動きがかなり鈍く
なったような気がします大丈夫かなゼリー
のヘリもねかなり
遅くなってますね食べてはいるんですけど
はいちょっと
ね動きが
鈍い気がしてますまそもそも令和5年の3
月に生まれてて今3月生まれで4567
18917ヶ月生きててヘラクレスの自分
って大体半年から1年って言われてて
大丈夫かなちょっともうちょっと様子見
たいと思い
ますはいいかがだったでしょうかはいメス
が死んでしまいましたがえその命は
受け継がれていると思いますもうかなりの
数の幼虫が生まれててもう見た
めちゃくちゃでかくなってたんですよ
ちゃんとしっかり育っていますでメスもも
いなくなって押すだけになったのでえこれ
以上卵が産むこともなく今生まれた大体何
匹だろう8090匹ぐらいかな90匹
ぐらいのちょっと幼虫をえ今からしっかり
育てていこうかなっていう感じですまこれ
から季節的には寒くなってくるので
ヘラクレスカブと大体20°前半が快適な
温度だと言われてる生き物なのでちょっと
寒いのだけは避けてあげたいのでしっかり
暖房をつけて温度管理しっかりしていき
たいと思いますまあとは幼虫どんどん
でかくなるとその分容器も大きくしなきゃ
いけないのでまちゃあのヘラクレスラボカ
シェルタの中もちょっと改造しなきゃなと
思ってますでこれから幼虫もっと成長する
とさぎになっていくと思うのでまさぎに
なった時どうすればいいのかがちょっと
まだよくわからないのでそれまでに色々
ちゃんと調べたりお話聞いたりして
しっかりとヘラクレスにしていきたいと
思います今後のヘラクレスラブがとても
楽しみですでもこれ全部成長になったら
90匹ぐらいのヘラクレスになっちゃうん
でしょうえどうする欲しい人いますちなみ
に育てるのはめちゃくちゃ簡単です温と
調性さえできれば全然問題ないので絶対
成虫そんないてもなって思うの
でちょっとどうしようか
なブリーダーになるかちょっとまだ何も
決めてないですけどとりあえずちゃんと
育てたいと思いますじゃ
[音楽]
な